This episode of DNews is brought to you by
the all-new G Flex 2, from LG.
Life’s Good
Water repellent metals?
Yup, that’s a thing now.
Hi gang, Amy here for DNews.
We’ve all seen corroded metals, whether
it’s the wall of an abandoned building or
an old pipe that’s sprung a leak.
Metals corrode because we use them in environments
where they are chemically unstable; only copper
and the precious metals like gold, silver,
and platinum, exist in nature in their metallic
state.
More common metals like iron are processed
from minerals and unstable, particularly in
the presence of water.
Preventing corrosion usually means adding
a chemical coating to a metal’s surface,
making it hydrophobic.
At CES 2015, Belgium-based Europlasma, a global
leader in low pressure plasma technology,
showcased its nanocoating technology for the
electronics industry.
The Nanofics coating makes any electronics
highly water and oil repellant.
The problem with any kind of hydrophobic coatings
that they can wear off.
But we might not need these kinds of chemical
coatings much longer.
Two scientists from the University of Rochester
recently led a team that developed a laser-patterning
technique that makes metal hydrophobic without
the need for any kind of coating.
They’ve also used the same technique to
make metals absorbent, metals that can pull
water along uphill on a surface.
It all comes down to the pattern lasered onto
the metal.
By creating an intricate pattern of micro-
and nanoscale structures on the metal’s
surface using ultra-short powerful bursts,
structures that become an intrinsic part of
the metal, giving it completely new qualities.
This process can make an ordinary metal a
multifunctional surface that repels water
and absorbs light.
This process makes the surface so resistant
to water that droplets actually bounce along
the surface.
It’s actually more slippery than teflon!
A drop of water would roll off this lasered
metal if you tilt it to just 5 degrees.
This kind of resurfacing could have widespread
applications.
Metal surfaced in this way could prevent rust
and corrosion and simplify issues of anti-icing.
In developing countries, super hydrophobic
materials could make rainwater collection
far more efficient and create toilet facilities
that are far more sanitary.
In parts of the world lacking clean water
and healthcare, these would be significant
applications.
But we’re unfortunately a ways from that
happening.
It currently takes an hour to pattern a 1
inch by 1 inch metal.
The process will need to develop before it
can be applied to large structures like toilet
facilities.
Still, it’s pretty exciting.
What do you guys think?
How cool is it that we can change the surface
properties of a metal with lasers!?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
ask me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.